welcome to hillsdale college
my name is tim caspar i work at
hillsdale college
uh where i have for the past i guess 21
plus years now
during that time i've been fortunate to
have a ringside seat as the college has
been growing and improving and extending
its nationwide
reach
uh and all the while we're guided by the
same uh mission that college has always
been guided by since its founding in
1844
by the way for those of you who are as
as bad at math as i am that means the
college is 177
years old this year
here on campus the quality of the
students and faculty is better than ever
i'm sure i wouldn't make the cut
off campus more americans learn from
hillsdale college than ever before
well we go about our work
every day here on campus
under the direction and leadership of
our next speaker
he's been the pilot of the hillsdale
college ship since 2000
he received his ba from arkansas state
university and his m.a and ph.d in
government from the claremont graduate
school
he also studied at the london school of
economics and at worcester college
oxford university
where he served as director of research
for the late sir martin gilbert
the official biographer of winston
churchill
prior to his appointment as president of
hillsdale college he served for 15 years
as president of the claremont institute
for the study of statesmanship and
political philosophy
in 2012 due to martin gilbert's
declining health he assumed
responsibility for editing the final six
document volumes of the churchill
biography
and he saw the project through to
completion in 2019.
the biography all 31 volumes is
available from hillsdale college press
in 2015 he received the bradley prize
from the bradley foundation
and he's the author of a growing number
of books including most recently
churchill's trial winston churchill and
the salvation of free government
the part of his job that i think he
enjoys the most is teaching
he teaches a variety of courses
on subjects including aristotle the
constitution
c.s lewis and totalitarian novels
would you please welcome an author and
editor and professor of history and
politics he's the 12th president of
hillsdale college larry pjarne
[Applause]
i just found out we have a green room
back there
nobody tells me anything
welcome to the campus
uh i'm sorry to say that the current
secretary of state is not able to make
it
[Applause]
so we have this other guy
i know how many people saw my
granddaughter in the dining room right
and i know you really came for that
but there is this other guy
um
i'm just going to give you a short
report on the state of the college i can
summarize it in this
my worthless son-in-law who is however
the father of that beautiful
granddaughter
he told me coming out of homecoming we
won our homecoming game
and
homecoming here is more fun than a
barrel of monkeys
and uh he's walking behind and there's
these two undergraduates he doesn't know
them and one says the other
is homecoming this much fun at a normal
college
[Laughter]
it tells you what we think about
ourselves
our speaker is the immediate past
secretary of state
he was a congressman from kansas
he was a cavalry officer that means a
tank commander
he went to west point he graduated top
of his class
there are famous generals especially
george pickett of the pickett's charge
at the battle of gettysburg who
graduated last in their class
i always thought that must be more
honorable than first in his class but
our the secretary graduated first
he went to harvard law school
where he was on the law review
he uh
he graduated first in his class
it's funny you know he doesn't seem that
smart
yeah he does yeah he does
he is an extremely important man
uh
because in these trials that we're going
through
somebody who's serious and a fighter
and has experience
it turns out there's a lot of things
going wrong in america
and they emanate from washington d.c
our speaker not has been in the middle
of all that
he was in the congress
when donald trump was elected
he was appointed head of the cia
and he gives
you can ask him about it in the q a
he he gives good reports of the spirit
of
most everybody there
and then he went to a different kind of
place
the united states department of state
and
that's a mess
but experience with that
because it's the archetype of the mess
right they don't
work for us anymore back there
and that's shouldn't even be a
controversial thing to say
because the form of government does not
tie them to our will anymore
and the form that we have today was
deliberately chosen
in things that are copious in moves that
are copiously recorded because it had
that feature
that experts would rule in the name of
their expertise
this man has been in the belly of that
beast
now sometime long about 2014 i met him
because
tom cotton senator cotton
also from arkansas and therefore my
cousin
i heard the secretary say tonight that
he's from kansas and he's got 200
cousins in in kansas
they're not sufficiently inbred
[Laughter]
tom cotton's wife anna
whom my wife and i introduced tom cotton
to
turns out she's it's the weirdest thing
in the world she's a green bay pankers
fan
and the packers were
yeah they won the other night didn't
they uh
and the packers were playing in the
playoffs and tom cotton called me up and
invited him himself over
to a little house we own in washington
dc
we don't own a house in hillside
michigan my wife says we live above the
shop
so it's a nice shop but it's not ours
um
i'm coming over and i'm to watch the
packers and i'm bringing
pompeo
and so mike pompeo and his wife susan
and anna cotton and i and my wife penny
we watched all afternoon a playoff game
that fortunately the packers won or
it would have been miserable
and
i saw what kind of fella he is
he commanded abram's tanks
on the edge of the soviet union before
it collapsed
what what that does to a person in my
experience is it
turns them into sort of like jocks
the humor is assertive
and good too
and
makes them servants
because you know they have to foreshadow
their death any day
what if the soviets come across the
border
he was close to that border for a long
time
i told him today i i do i'm very fond of
him i think he's a pretentious man for
the future of the country whatever the
surface service he does will be
but but i told him today
my favorite greek word it turns out i
just love the way it sounds is spudios
doesn't that sound great don't you like
that word
and what it means is a person of serious
moral worth
and
when a person like that gets experience
in the highest places
they're in a position to do better next
time and they did well the first time
and only that preparation
combined with continuity
can rescue this situation
and so i introduce to you
an important man
mike pompeo
[Applause]
thank you
lovely introduction
[Applause]
i was saying to dr aaron that much
applause before you speak is dangerous
uh doctor thank you for that uh kind uh
introduction he told me that drink uh
greek word had no idea what it meant so
he was right i'm not as smart
as you might think
so i have a number of things i want to
share with things that are on my heart
tonight things we can
have a conversation about when i take
some questions at the end i'm i'm
privileged i'm now out of the
administration so you'll get a chance to
get mike pompeo unplugged
uh
my wife would always joke in the
administration said mike you know you go
on
on the sunday shows and you know you
don't smile and say honey we're talking
about really dangerous tough things
now i can smile
it's been a long eight months
and i'll talk about some of those things
not because it's been
impactful to me personally but because
of so much what's happened in this these
eight months has impacted every one of
you and every american
i
i was walking over here tonight we
walked from the president's office over
to his home and then over here
i know this place a little bit hillsdale
i know it's greatness it's importance to
america
it's a place that imparts character it's
a place
that imparts faith and freedom
it sparks memories for me of another
great institution the place that i went
to school the united states military
academy at west point
it feels in some ways as they serve
these important missions together
alongside of each other
that one was founded in 1802 this one in
1844
and they have deep roots
in american history
dr army joking about i was a good
student and most of the generals that
you know who led america's charges
weren't
i was deeply mindful of that
you know as a cadet there there was just
a single standard for excellence from my
perspective it was a general the army
douglas macarthur i lived in macarthur
barracks
for a short time he said quote that
history fails to record a single
precedent
in which nations subject to moral decay
have not passed into political and
economic decline
leading to ultimate national disaster
for he believed only that a spiritual
awakening
could overcome the danger
you all know this history leaves its
marks
dr aaron was talking a little bit
earlier about history the crisis of the
third century brought the roman empire
to the edge of collapse
due to military over-extension
immigration
without a civilization plague inflation
political disunity
and insurgents
think about those
but our country's principles remain
intact
for their instigation
reaches past this world and indeed comes
from another
but for the tree of liberty for the tree
of liberty to have roots america must be
defended against enemies both foreign
and domestic i spent
the last four years working diligently
to try and do that
and the question for us tonight is
will it
will we we're in our third century now
and it must not signify our dissent the
world is depending on it
to prevail we must inscribe
faith in a higher power
allegiance to america's founding
documents and a commitment to american
exceptionalism
i'll talk about how we tried to do that
i i want to speak tonight about four
issues that we confronted and they
touched deeply on our present moment as
well first
the erosion of our foundational
principles you all you are teaching this
to the next generation here how to make
sure that that doesn't continue to erode
second
the left's progressive domination of our
central
institutions
third i want to talk about the threat
that is imposed upon us all today from
the chinese communist party it is not
disconnected from the first two
and then finally i want to talk about
the things that we can all do each of us
can do
to avert this disaster
look you all know this
the families will always be the
irreplaceable unit of humankind period
full stop
the expression of faith
anchors families through prayer
and love
america's churches synagogues mosques
and temples provide moral and physical
sustenance to families in need
and character that which you are trying
to instill in students here at hillsdale
is the essence
of the united states of america
the proclamation by men and women of
faith
that god's relationship was with the
individual and not the collective
is at the center of this it is
absolutely essential i saw this as
secretary of state we we have to marshal
our authority to reach past our broken
media and corrupt elites to return
america to its moral core
reminds me i was
my son who's a little bit older called
me and and said he'd seen the washington
post had written a piece and it said
america's worst secretary of state ever
that had followed on peace in the new
york times just the day before said the
same thing these were not disconnected
they were they were they were aiming for
me
and so my son knowing i'm pretty tough
the first one goes by the second when he
says i should call and check in with dad
so i always try to take calls from my
son and he says dada did you see the
post today and i said i i saw it and uh
he said he said look dope because i was
doing some research and this fellow
named elihu washburn
and i said yes and he said he was the he
was a secretary of state for only 11
days surely you're better than him
yeah
so we started a club called we're number
two
our our children our families
are what guide us
uh
in traversing all of the challenges we
face today look at the digital landscape
what our kids are suffering from it is
addictive
cyber immersion technology induced
isolation like we've not seen in the
united states before
and it was in isolation which the
pandemic was amplified
the threat posed by this loneliness the
separation from family and the
constriction of perspectives
has to be addressed
algorithms computers i was an engineer
by training
algorithms computers social media cannot
substitute
for faith and family
we have to stay connected to that
tremendous achievements have been made
possible through this technology it's
great
but it can never replace a parent
comforting a sick child or a person of
faith holding the hand of someone in
dire need
when i was a student living in
massachusetts i had the opportunity to
tutor two young kids who were from a
pretty tough neighborhood
i taught them that arithmetic mattered
it mattered not only in the numbers but
the discipline that it would be required
for them to master the subject that was
in front of them but i knew too it would
be a gateway for them
but i knew this i knew our time together
mattered even more
neither of these children's had a father
that time with an adult
was scarce for them and i suspect it was
irreplaceable
we each
all of us here must proclaim
the eternal relevance of strong families
i spent four years serving as america's
secretary of state i get asked what's
the biggest challenge facing the united
states and the expectations i'll say
vladimir putin chairman kim xi jinping
all
big challenges
the single biggest risk to the united
states of america is in our schools and
in our families
howard
[Applause]
our government should never promote
policies that disrupt this ideal but we
have lots of programs lots of programs
today you all know them that disparage
the value of fathers and this this has
to end
it has to end for the children it has to
end for the fathers but it has to end
for our country too we must never
tolerate
that which is a front to the basic
system
the basis of all humanity
look when the current secretary of
health and human services
testified before the senate
he couldn't bring himself to say the
word mother
i go look at the tape
we're in danger of no longer living in a
country but an asylum
when you hear language like this faith
venerates mothers as the bringers of
life
but he couldn't bring himself to say it
under oath
i don't know what he called his mom
we know these people these are the
people that generate american history
church and state
church and state are something that the
left has tried to separate
uh in our administration we tried never
to let that happen our nation suffers
for
too much for having taken the concept of
separation church and state to mean that
we have to tear the two apart
but of course the two statements aren't
synonymous i'll never forget i was the
cia director i climbed off a place a
plane in a pretty dark place
climbed down the stairs
it was three in the morning and a fellow
presses into my palm of my hand a small
pocket bible
i was in a hurry i i hopped into my
vehicle and i opened the bible and he
said to me
said mr director you have been a light
in my life
i don't tell that story about me but
because it gets to the central thesis
of refusing to separate one's own
personal faith and one's commitment to
america and our constitution they're
deeply intertwined
thomas jefferson wrote that the almighty
god hath created the mind free
and then later
he stated that the establishment caused
which forbade the inauguration of a
state religion but built a wall of
separation between the church of state
but he knew better he it was
misunderstood it was interpreted by our
courts i think intentionally
because the wall's purpose was to
protect the expression of religion
and its infringements from government
we in our arrogance have banished
religion from our schools and public
spaces
and in doing so have wrought enormous
havoc
we've forgotten our founders intent and
done great harm to the republic as a
result of it
john adams had it right his inaugural
address he said simply patronize every
rational effort to encourage every
institution
for propagating knowledge virtue and
religion among all classes
as the only means of preserving our
constitution
later in that same address he stated
that he considered a respect to
christianity among the best
recommendations for public service
and to that i say amen
kept me going during my four years as
well
and i must say
i gave a speech it was in cairo egypt
the opening line of this speech which my
speechwriters tried to take out not once
not twice but three times
i simply said that i am an evangelical
christian standing there in cairo
i must say that i hear about those
remarks more than any other from leaders
of every faith who said we appreciated
you saying that it showed candor it
showed discipline it showed a true
commitment to something beyond one's
self and we value that although our
faith is different we value that too
this gets back to what thomas jefferson
was talking about when he came to an
understanding of faith and america and
the importance of keeping it in our
public sphere
look it was never an intent nor could it
have been
at the time of our nation's creation for
in that age humanity and its progress
were viewed as inseparable
from our judeo-christian heritage and
our belief in god
our government must never be permitted
to cloak god's word
yet a powerful assemblage of elites
disparages it every day you saw them
close bars and leave churches
open you know i first had the chance to
think about this idea
of separating church and state when i
was traveling from washington while i
was still in law school
i recall the moment i i was
doing a little bit of a history tour
with a friend and we were outside the
capitol at the eastern pediment of the
supreme court just around the corner
from the capitol building it's not
usually seen because visitors don't come
in that way it's at the tail end of
capitol hill
the pediments freeze depicts
history's lawgivers
seated
centrally moses holds the two famous
massive tablets and they're blank in
this particular rendition
i couldn't figure out exactly why there
were no words i thought about it and
then i did some reading i came to
understand that it was because the ten
commandments differ in their wording and
in their order from the protestant roman
catholic orthodox and jewish faiths
therefore if the words of the
commandments had been carved into the
stone or so the
craftsman believed america's temple to
justice would show a preference for one
faith as amongst the others
he knew that wasn't
its place
and so desiring
that the religious wars of europe would
not find refuge in america our founders
forbade just that preference in the
establishment of a state religion
but make no mistake about it the wisdom
of the eastern impediment
continues
there's another meaning
the essence the essence of this idea of
church and state and its separation here
in our nation was to make sure that
there was no deification
of the state
it is are not our god
we have bigger
bigger callings
the truth was first enunciated by jesus
christ render therefore to caesar that
things that which are caesar's and to
god the things that are god's
note that he did not say that certain
human activities were outside of god's
authority no he proclaimed the divine
and the physical spheres of humankind to
be together a means to live within both
in our earthly constraints
and still obey the father
our founders knew this
when i came to the state department
our human rights doctrine was a mess we
had diplomats across the world talking
about human rights that i was deeply
unfamiliar with for my study of our
constitution the declaration of
independence in america's history
and so i sought to do my best to corral
it we created something we called the
commission on unalienable rights it was
chaired by a woman named marianne
glendon who'd been a former ambassador
to the vatican and as a teacher at
harvard law school
i asked her to chair this commission
and the idea was to reground american
foreign policy and our human rights in
the american tradition
i was sued by over 300 organizations
within 24 hours of the announcement
yes and then several hundred more times
uh
i wanted to take us back to the
tradition that hillsdale college teaches
its students
and the importance of understanding that
as we dealt with our friends and our
adversaries around the world i wanted to
speak about these fundamental rights we
know them from our declaration
the pursuit of life and liberty and
happiness that are at america's core
and so much of what we talk about in our
rights discourse today is so deeply
disconnected and indeed undermines those
central understandings of our nation
our founders comprehended the horrific
excesses that issued from the
deification of emperors like in places
like rome our founders understood that
the wrath of the kings and queens of
europe
unleashed when they believed themselves
truly to be divine
never idolize the state this is the
essence of marxism it's what general
secretary xi jinping wants you to do
here in america
our government is not god we must not
allow it to impose itself as an object
of worship
climate change shouldn't be worshipped
either
the state's bounty is not created by any
miracle but it's seized only to be given
out
and offered to constituents
to whom it has incurred debt
if state and church
are conjoined
so are there dominions
this is not america
it's more like iran
and now today afghanistan
status always you know them you see them
they're now occupying enormous positions
of power standards pretend
that it is heaven on earth
but such a prize never will be realized
if this affront is to be vanquished each
of us must insist that faith never be
banished from the public square
or from our schools
the second point is the left domination
of our institutions you all see it
every day
some of you sent your kids here to this
place
to help teach them
that this doesn't have to be our
nation's present
crisis have been implicated by elites
who
who posture beneficence as they practice
rapaciousness
woke billionaires esconced on their
super yachts lectures about climate
change as they flaunt their own
admonitions
dante wrote a hypocrite's outward
appearance passes for holiness
but under the show lies the terrible
weight of this deceit
such persons cannot be entrusted
they cannot be trusted but the default
they define the new ruling class here in
america i'm counting on you all to make
sure this does not continue it can't
stand for our country cannot withstand
deceit
cloaked
feigned
concerned for the dispossessed
our strengths in some ways
have been turned against us
hollywood and america's corporations
were critical elements of our nation's
soft power
i didn't benefit from that as secretary
of state
it involves global engagement in the
sharing of goals to obtain national
objectives
america's soft power once seemed
completely invincible
hollywood our media press and
international businesses
are no longer the forces that they were
for democratic development and for
market creation throughout the world
this has now changed fundamentally
hollywood
completely infiltrated by china
this is not the first time that a male
11 of foreign power has tried to
influence our media
we all know the history in the 30s where
nazis endeavored to subject american
films to censorship
not only in germany but around the world
their plans were in fact stymied by
counterintelligence network led by a
patriot attorney named leon lewis who
was the first national secretary of the
anti-defamation league
today these big hollywood conglomerates
dominate that controls american media
american media publishing and news
sources
you all are subjected to it day in and
day out
thus access access to chinese markets
creates substantial pressure for them to
kowtow and obey beijing's dictates
jin zhang's security bureau and
propaganda departments
a place and a leadership holding a
million people in bondage today where
genocide is taking place they were
thanked by disney in the closing credits
of their film mulan
where i ask is this company's for
concern
for xinjiang's muslims who are subject
to this genocide
you should know this too wall street
it's caved
there are over 250 chinese companies
listed on our exchanges here in the
united states they're capitalized by
more than 21
trillion dollars
major u.s companies are now owned or
influenced by entities that front for
the chinese communist party
but an even greater threat is upon us
too the world's largest asset managers
are pouring into china today billions of
your dollars in investment capital from
pension funds in california
to michigan to my home state of kansas
this situation is so fraught with risk
that george soros now recommends that
congress pass legislation empowering the
sec
to limit the flow of funds to china
that is the first time i've said a nice
thing about him in my 57 years
something about blind squirrels and
acorns
president trump and i working with
congress did our best we designed
financial architecture to defend scores
of millions of americans who without
their knowledge have had their savings
invested in the chinese communist party
and chinese companies
beijing's fundraising
beijing's fundraise
is opaque
its instruments are passive
they're in big
assemblages of mutual funds money that
will flow
to china and not to america
they finance the security apparatus the
certi security architecture in china
and they are erecting a powerful
powerful
capability that threatens each of us
this summer over 500 billion in chinese
stock value was lost gutting american
investors overseas because the ccp
cracked down on its technology companies
and its other businesses they did that
just for political power but when our
woke corporations
via may disapprove of georgia's actions
to enforce basic election integrity but
are silent on china's rampage we have to
recognize that businesses as well as
wall street firms have been bought
or intimidated
such feigned moral rectitude and
certitude at home
is a figly for moral cowardice abroad
we can't allow this to contend to
continue to happen
we can fix it
we simply must find the will
chinese companies the debate genocide
slave labor and the construction of
concentration camps cannot be
underwritten by america's pension fund
or american investors we must not find
fund these chinese corporations that
advance manufacturing in china so that
they can build weapons that will one day
threaten
your children and your grandchildren
and i do not intend to rest
until the ruinous underwriting of a
totalitarian
police state is brought to an abrupt
trial
[Applause]
this administration not so much
but the american people get it
we must
remove this financial dagger before it
destroys us
education or
indoctrination in our schools
is a decision that each of will have to
make it's connected to the china
challenge
the fight we must engage is sustained by
a sound education this is what i love
about this place
to nullify what someone may become
so that even they themselves do not know
what god intended them to be
is absolutely inhuman i can't imagine
what my life would have been like had i
not had the privilege to attend the
united states military academy
in my freshman year i went to a place
called los amigos high school we were
the lobos the friendly wolves go figure
had a professor's name was daryl
manderscheid
he taught me geometry and advanced
algebra
he challenged me every day
he set the bar ever higher
and because of his support and care i
was able to explore logic
and the beauty of mathematics
that foundation that foundation that he
fostered was broad i grew to understand
that to learn one must truly listen
to solve complex questions one has to
make sure that they have a rigorous
analysis this is obligatory
these ideas that professor mandershad
taught me are with me to this day
and i thank god that he blessed me with
this
my wife susan and i pray that our son
nick got the same kind of learning in
his school
and we are proud parents of him because
we think it mostly stuck
as i as i described in smaller circles
he's a good kid most days
knowledge around the world is absolutely
exploding but paradox our capacity to
assimilate and employ that knowledge
wisely seems more limited than ever to
me
i saw this in my time these last four
years and most especially in my time
serving in congress for six years
it's because we can't intelligently
speak
nor or work faster
than we can actually think but the
internet and social media demand that we
do
thoughtless responses are rife
i may have given one or two myself from
time to time
we we all recognize that school choice
and not socialist policies of pro and
and privatization must happen to reform
our schools indeed
it is your 1776 curriculum
that should be taught each place and
everywhere
i get asked i get asked from time to
time where should i read to get my
knowledge and i say a little more of the
constitution a little less of the 1619
project is a darn a darn good start
we um
we fled washington dc we got as far as
chantilly virginia that's where we live
today
that's in loudoun county i don't know if
you've all seen it in the news
we know the critical race theory that
has been taught in those places parents
are not going to have any of it's
glorious
we know it's neither critical nor a
theory
it doesn't teach the critical thinking
that's required for an unbiased
explication of the complex issues that
face us
the 1619 project talks about america's
systemically racist and a racist
founding we know that's not true
the screed itself's been condemned by
scholars at hillsdale and throughout the
country
and yet you can't imagine how many
places that is still central to what it
is we're teaching the next generation
look a theory you know it's a theory is
an explanation for phenomenon that are
widely accepted by a reputable scholarly
community
critical race theory was put forward as
a political instrument
defined by its propagandic intent
and the prism of race through which the
woke demand we see the world
is a prism of limitations it restricts
us and we can never accept it
we know this we know that the new york
times stood behind the 1619 project
because for them race is everything
what who believes this
we
we have too much common sense we've made
too much progress as a nation to return
to a time when people were judged by the
color of their skin
critical race theory throws us back to
that day it's their sole intent it wants
to face martin luther's martin luther
king's central and most monumental
contributions to america
fine teach american slavery teach the
history of our constitution but this is
a noble nation founded on a central
understanding that no nation has ever
equaled
there is no place in any primary
secondary school in any college or
university for students to be taught
that race color religion or economic
status determine what they can
potentially be
or what they can achieve
we should never deny
the terrible chapters in our nation's
history
our mistreatment of indigenous nations
and peoples
the internment of citizens of japanese
descent by president roosevelt and his
administration's turning away a ship
whose jewish passengers simply fled the
third
right but america's greatness its
uniqueness is our ability to reflect
upon that and learn and grow and advance
against the steadfast principles that
our founders bequeath to us
we'll never allow our country to again
segregate or deny freedom to any of its
citizens and any curriculum that
categorizes school children by the color
of their skin as crt does
on the basis of their ancestry of
religion is an obscenity
and obscenities don't belong in your
children's classrooms and america is not
going to tolerate it we must fight
[Applause]
china i've alluded to it already the
united states and the people's republic
of china are fundamentally different
because we honor the individual
and they venerate the collective period
full stop
we now have a big decision to make
theirs is a
a hive mind in which individualism is an
illusion
this must never happen here in the
united states china's
china's past deficit and power
suppressed its ambitions
but this constraint this constraint has
collapsed the old notion of hide your
time and bide your strength is gone from
china today
its attainment of wealth has propelled
its
quest to displace the united states as
the world's leading power
the spread of the wuhan virus
which china facilitated
by spurring international flights from
that city
while limiting internal travel
murdered millions of people
our country's losses
are one and a half times the number of
americans killed
in world war ii
china's deployment of stealth aircraft
today the construction of its first
super carrier and the expansion of its
nuclear arsenal
are threats
to our homeland
and today genocidal acts against muslim
minorities
or new imperialism
the belt and road initiative china's
effort to commandeer the rest of the
world
is in full push
and match xi xingping's intentions and
ambitions
set alone agreements with developing
countries that seek to use national
assets as
i told leaders all around the world
during my entire form years they are
prepared to call the loan
china's theft of our intellectual
property destroyed millions of jobs here
in the united states cumulative losses
exceed 2 trillion dollars
that's just the last decade
this sum if divided could have made one
in every 40 american families instant
millionaires it's staggering
china's business software if you look at
a laptop in china
is nearly all pirated from american
businesses
the result is that software expenditures
in china are a fraction compared to that
here in the united states from american
companies conveying an enormous unearned
competitive advantages to the chinese
firms
this must cease
but for 50 years republicans and
democrats and alike in washington
just turned away
for after all this was china
the trump administration was the first
to confront what will be the great
challenge of the next 245 years for the
united states of america
i have only partial answers to this but
we know that part of the answer lies in
sanctions and countervailing cyber
efforts
but such measures
are inadequate
if american jobs and wealth are to be
preserved
we're going to have to take
serious action
we know how to do this in the united
states
so here's the closing question
xi jinping has said many times to his
politburo
that america is in decline
i don't believe it for a second indeed i
believe that decline is a choice
but will america muster
will america muster the will
to avert this disaster
history teaches yes
but great men had expectations for every
american the catastrophe that is
afghanistan
is one of the greatest self-inflicted
wounds
that we've seen at least in recent
american history was caused by an
administration who had a different
understanding of american exceptionalism
whose words were simply not backed by
deeds
or by prudent policies
derived from an understanding of america
a theocratic monstrosity has now
declared itself victorious despite the
irreplaceable loss
of thousands of american lives some of
whom were my friends
and they killed citizens of our friends
and allies as well
american military power
is the guarantor of our promises
as america's most senior diplomat i
counted on the capacity for american
force to back up the things that were in
america's interests and i he the
military counted on me to make sure that
we seldom had to deploy it
it remains a force it remains a force
without equal but it must be properly
understood this strength
can be destroyed
by politicized military leaders who
shine accountability and care more about
appearances than the mission
that the constitution lays forth for
them
where are the generals and admirals who
will tender their resignations before
complying with politically motivated
orders which have put our nation
at real risk
in 1949
in 1949 an admirals were vote revolt
protested actions that could have
crippled the united states navy fleet
admirals earnest fleet admiral ernest
king chester nimitz
and haley all
active services left active service
consequential rank testified before
congress against the truman
administration's plans
and the korean war had proved them right
the pentagon must not be composed of
pinstripe diplomats we have enough of
those
it must not be construed of the woke we
have enough of those too
we need generals who understand their
mission
i was criticized
often
but i was criticized too for getting rid
of some of these types
at the state department
my sadness was only that i could not
have done more
recouping from a failed strategy of
nation-building the trump administration
was determined to reduce america's
commitment in afghanistan you only need
to read president trump's twitter
account to know that
but we had
the handle on this we were prepared to
do so in a way that reflected the
greatness of america would have kept our
people safe and we would have done so in
an orderly and structured manner
for reasons that seem to hinge on
appearance as president biden picked
september 11th
as a date certain for american departure
rather than understanding the realities
and all the planning that me and my team
had overseen they cast it aside
i uh as secretary said i worked to build
upon the work i'd done as cia director
to aid president trump in thinking
concretely about how we would execute on
his commitment to the american people
that we would get our young men and
women home from that place and execute a
withdrawal from afghanistan while
preserving the hard-won progress that we
had achieved there
what we'd established
was the certainty of action
if the taliban didn't do what we told
them they must do you all have seen how
many of you seen the picture of me
standing there with mueller broader yes
new york times likes to make it famous
muller baradar understood donald trump
and mike pompeo
he he knew that if they violated the
understandings that they had reached
with us that we would deploy
overwhelming force to inflict unbearable
costs upon them
real losses
leaving the extremists
in terrible situation i made them know
in the meetings with them and by phone
as did president trump that if they
failed to live up to the promises they
made
that just like general qasim suleimani
the iranian leader who killed soulmar
americans they too
would never kill another american
that we understood how to use american
power in a way that reduced the
frequency with which we would have to do
so
that the demise
of the kudz force leader
the strike that we took
resounded to the taliban's consciousness
this administration threw it all away
i'd created a group we'd seen what
happened i was a young congressman i
served on the benghazi committee
i had seen what happened when the state
departments abandons its diplomats
abroad and i had worked diligently for
my entire time to build what we call the
contingency crisis and response bureau
it was designed to help in crises where
there were american diplomats in harm's
way
in june
of 2021 this administration disbanded
that very organization
what the bite administration never
recognized is that our multiple
agreements concerning america's
conditional departure from afghanistan
were made possible by our
administration's vow to use that
overwhelming force
our attainment of energy independence
and our decisive action
in destroying the isis caliphate
illustrated to all in the world
our resolve
when we moved our embassy
to jerusalem
president trump made clear that we would
continue to honor the commitments that
he had made
and the taliban knew this
by removing the isis terrorist threat
and by changing the status of jerusalem
we eliminated obstacles to progress
the abraham accords a truly historic set
of understandings made possible by great
leaders like prime minister netanyahu
and the crown prince in the emirates
they were made possible because of
american leadership our tenacity
caused those four muslim countries to
have confidence that they could make
peace
with the jewish state
if we'd have had a second term
there'd be more
i can't prove it but i know it in my
heart together
we would have
we would have erected prodigious
barriers to terrorism
these triumphs these things about which
i played a small part for which i am
intensely proud
were disregarded by this administration
because acknowledging our breakthroughs
was deemed by the bite administration as
a far greater sin
than abandonment of our allies or our
principles
afghanistan today is lost it's progress
nullified
it's women dehumanized
it is incomprehensible that we departed
from bagram air base while the taliban
attacked
this fortified airfield would have been
the only possibility to get every
american out it was protected it was an
avenue for egress and evacuation so that
we would not leave any american behind
and then we surrendered billions of
dollars in equipment
they they valued above
above and beyond
by the terrorists and by the chinese and
the russian engineers who at this very
moment are likely duplicating our
peerless technologies
this taliban effort may think they have
won a miraculous victory but i'm
confident that america remains strong
if america is to be harmed it will only
be through our own folly
one day
one day we will restore and reclaim
american greatness i pray that it is
soon
we have to make sure that our enemies
understand that we will strike you
without pity
if you murder innocents
threaten american interests we'll strike
you
we will know
that this is through american honored
honor just as our founders had
articulated
i and you came out on this night you all
say no to decline
america's path
our future is in our own hands we must
not choose defeat
neglect or shame
i went to cairo to give that speech for
the singular purpose it was a little bit
personal to me
president obama had stood in that place
and conducted what has become known as
apology tour
i wanted to go stand in the exact same
place he spoke at al-azhar university
and so i was set and determined to go
there uh about two weeks out my team
came in
uh including my security team and said
sir you're not going to be able to speak
at alazar university
and i said why he said we're not sure
that we can
we can protect you adequately and i said
the president of the united states spoke
from there
and he said they said yes they liked him
look i grew up in california
and spent a lot of my summers in
america's heartland in kansas uh
dr aaron was talking about all my
cousins in kansas everybody thought
that'd be a big political advantage but
i know those cousins if i got half of
their votes i am lucky
i have been at the thanksgiving dinner
table with them
neither of my parents had the chance to
graduate from college
my mother was a clerk she was employed
by the boeing company in wichita kansas
as part of the war effort in the late
1940s
my father grew up in new mexico he's a
salesman
he served a short stint the united
states navy the korean war
but they taught me something in the same
way i'm confident you taught your kids
something they taught me to respect the
importance of hard work
so did rising before dawn to help my
uncle jim on our farm in winfield kansas
i remember being there at 10 years old i
thought i was working i am confident i
was more trouble than i was worth
but by the time i was 14 i was driving
trucks and doing my best to lift a bale
hey
i knew what it meant to work hard i
i cherished too my after school job in
costa mesa california
for paid for my first car a really old
fiat x19 i was a killer good scooper at
baskin-robbins
our purported masters in washington will
soon have added 10 trillion dollars to
the national debt think about that
a trillion dollars is a ridiculous
amount of money
stacks and stacks
in each and every stack a million
ten trillion dollars is more than thirty
thousand dollars for every each each and
every one of you
for a family of four that's 120 k in new
debt that may happen yet this week
would anyone here trust speaker pelosi
to mortgage your family's future
i didn't hear yes uh no no need no need
for a second on the motion
look
um we we we're going to get this right i
i'm deeply committed to it we um there
is an awakening taking place there's a
reclamation
thanks to the geniuses running our
government today we're seeing
significant inflation too without wealth
creation or substantial growth this will
hurt everybody in the middle class by
putting government in charge
these leaders have performed their
miracle of making the stupendous
vanish
we we can do much better and i'm
confident that we will
but we have to choose this
and i believe that we will
the taliban think they've got their
moment
i know differently you know differently
free will and its exercise are deeply
embedded in our constitution
my time in service these four years
in administration
that was prepared to defend
the important things
the hard things the things that matter
to hard-working men and women all across
america
was cut abruptly short
as i have traveled these last now
eight months
been to a couple of dozen states
and i listen
i'm very confident
the choice that the american people are
going to make
don't let xi jinping fool you
we are not in decline
our declaration of independence
has made a resilient people and our
constitution has provided a framework by
which those resilient people will
continue to rise
i i spent four years reading the
intelligence reports of cia director and
then working on some of the toughest
problems that the world faces
there were pretty dark days and pretty
dark moments and so i tend when i'm in
front of groups to speak about these
dark times these difficult challenges
they're real we must confront them
but i'm long on america
i believe deeply that we will reclaim
our sovereignty and our borders that we
will claim these central institutions
that we will push back against the
chinese communist party and that this
nation will not choose
to allow the next 245 years to deny the
very opportunities that permitted each
of us to be here tonight to be what our
children and grandchildren are living in
thank you for supporting this important
institution thank you all for coming out
tonight and i am happy to answer just
about any question
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you all
[Applause]
right bring it
hello all right yes i'm sorry where are
you over here gotcha yes ma'am yeah on
the left believe it or not so anyways uh
thank you for your speech tonight and um
i appreciate it and you're one of my
favorite people um who are leaders today
and i always feel like when i hear you
speak i'm like hearing the grown-ups
speak i do appreciate that i tried to
use my grown-up words tonight yes
so um boy what i wanted to ask is um so
when trump enacted executive order
13484 i believe on september 12th of
2018 and it was um
sanctions in the case of foreign
interference
in our
elections that would protect us
from what happened in our election so um
from your speech here tonight are you
saying that there was no foreign
interference in our elections in 2020
yeah definitely so remember i talked i
said i'd answer almost anything
no i'm
i i want to be a little careful here
because some of this some of the
knowledge that i have here is
knowledge that continues to be
classified but i think i can answer your
question in large measure
completely and
fully we've had foreigners trying to
interfere in our election for a long
time in the united states uh the left
went after the election of 2016 and then
ultimately
did so in a way that tried to undermine
the united states of america by somehow
suggesting that russian interference had
an impact on the outcome you'll know how
many democrats called president trump a
russian asset
look we know this we know this was a
hoax from the beginning it was false it
wasn't true and yet it took a little bit
away from
america's confidence in our election
system
so when i think about foreigners
interfering in our election
i know that we do a pretty good job in
protecting them from attacking our vote
tallies and vote counts
but the real way that they attack our
elections is through propaganda and
information warfare and you should know
they are enabled by large parts of the
united states media as well who
facilitated this very storyline for the
first two years of our administration
right it wasn't just adam schiff it was
also brian steller
right
aided and abetted
in the most serious way
we we watched what state legislatures
did
during this last election often under
the disguise of well we have to do this
because of the wuhan virus right we
can't go out we can't vote everybody
just toss a ballot in the mail
we each of us has a responsibility
to look forward to make sure that we
never have another election that we
don't have confidence in it's an
absolute imperative
as a secretary of state you all can
appreciate this
as a secretary of state we evaluated
elections all across the world almost
every week there'd be an election
somewhere and i would get a memo saying
uh country x had a crappy election
uh countrywide had a good free and fair
election we would often much like when i
was a high school basketball player
would give out most improved player
awards like like it was a bad election
it was better than their last one
we have to have one that's better than
our last one
and i don't mean in 2024 i mean in 2022
that requires a lot of effort it
requires you holding accountable your
state elected officials who in my
judgment many times republican state
elected officials did not do
the fundamental thing which they were
required to do they had the authority to
do it to do it well
and
they were pushed off of that target set
i'll leave to
voters to determine why they made that
set of decisions
we have to have a set of elections that
are determinative and i guess the last
thing i'd say here is we know how to do
this this is not particularly complex or
hard let's start by making sure there's
someone attesting to their
identification when they cast their
ballot
uh
it's just
there are building blocks
there are building blocks to save the
election safe elections that we must put
in place
yes sir
all right i'm sorry i'm gonna try i'm
just i'm trying i'm just i think i'm
gonna try and get to someone else if
that's okay yeah yes sir secretary
pompeo thank you so much for coming here
tonight my name is josiah lippencott i'm
a phd student here you spoke tonight
about totalitarian regimes over the past
year we've seen these lockdowns we've
seen mandates throughout the west an
increasing
large amount of biomedical security it
seems that these democratic regimes like
australia and then even here
have become increasingly repressive of
our basic rights and liberties including
the right to travel and it seems our
government is increasingly unaccountable
there was a shocking story that came out
just recently that there was a faction
in the cia for instance that intended to
or plan to assassinate julian assange so
it seems like we have an increasing
tendency toward unaccountability in uh
in our government just wondering if you
could speak to that here in the last let
me just answer that last one because
someone's going to go google that my
name is on it they assert that was me
that was trying to kill jonah so you
should know don't believe michael
issakov okay
so don't believe everything you read in
yahoo news
is a good start
your core point though your core point
about american the about the
administrative state and the closure of
america and the denial of liberty is
fundamentally true
i would say this i don't think this is a
particularly new phenomenon this didn't
just start
at least since the 1960s the left has
had an active effort to reduce the space
for freedom and ideas and for liberty
that by controlling the media that i
spoke about there are lots of tools that
have been used i will say that the this
this wuhan virus lowered the water level
so we saw a lot more rocks
i think the rocks were there before the
virus we also saw and and this is maybe
how i'll finish the answer to this
question we also saw
how few americans were willing to push
back against this
um i you know i can't tell you
i'll say this differently
i had a handful of pastors call me
when they were being told that they
couldn't worship
in their space in a way that they deemed
safe
i was proud that those pastors told me
said
i'm going to do it.
and
[Applause]
there is a long history of civil
disobedience in the united states of
america
i'm not suggesting that it is not
complex
but i can say this
if we don't hold accountable
leaders
and i don't just mean we think when we
think of leaders we think of presidents
we think of state u.s senators
how about your sheriff's office
about your school board
how about your city council
these people impact our lives we saw
that we saw city councils issue these
crazy things
hardy americans must push back against
this we have to go retake
i learned a lot i know more about how to
do this now than i did too four years
ago
maybe everybody's a little naive until
they get kicked in the head
this is a fight worth having
about freedom and making sure
[Applause]
and make and making sure
we are not to where this we are this is
not this is not the ccp here in the
united states today but we started from
such a face that's so fundamentally
different that the risk that it falls
here quickly is real and so time is upon
us so thanks for that question it's an
important one
yes
thank you again for coming tonight
um
i'm going to just tell you my background
real quick i
for the last four decades plus i spent
my career in healthcare started in
pharmacy school and medical school then
trained at the cleveland clinic in
neurosurgery and then practiced for over
20 years in solo practice in columbus
indiana then retired about seven and a
half years ago so what i'm about to
share with you i share with a heavy
heart and i want everyone to understand
that
they should really think about this i
wrote it down so it could be as brief as
possible the hospital and health care
system has been captured by a corrupt
bureaucracy and corporatist control that
is nothing less than fascism
public-private partnerships like the fda
nih cdc
are putting out guidelines that state
health departments hospitals and
conventional medical practices owned by
larger institutions are blindly
following
the prep act
immunized them for medical legal
liability the needs of the individual
patient no longer are a priority and
this is an utter betrayal of a most
solemn obligation between a doctor and a
patient and the institutions where these
doctors work
nations like india are more open to
giving the public access to a full
spectrum of early treatment options that
are now being demonized and outlawed in
western nations by the mass media and
bureaucratic cronies
follow the money sure but also follow
the ideology
a continuously sick american population
health weakened american military are as
great a threat to our nation's survival
as any diabolical schemes of the ccp and
the global collectivist certainly
weakening and discrediting our health
system is a big part of their plans the
public must seek out the truth in
science for themselves so my question to
you is
i know you've had a front row seat to
this issue as well and uh people need to
start getting better control of their
health care so what
solutions or options would you suggest
at this point yeah
well i i'm not i'm unlikely in the time
allotted to be able to solve america's
health care problems tonight
um but i do have three thoughts uh i
worked on this a little bit when i was
in congress but three thoughts first you
got to the politization it's absolutely
true certainly saw in the pandemic
response in our administration as well
i was working on the external piece of
this
but
vice president's task force are working
on the domestic one make no mistake
about it senior
american officials were not not doing
science they were doing politics
career people
second
you lived it more up close and personal
my experiences with the medical system
are mostly
just me going in to see doc
i still think it's the case in spite of
all the shortcomings you identified that
most people if given a choice would
choose our system over
anybody else's you talked about indian
outliers
fair enough
i think most parents given the choice if
they said you want to go through the nih
system in britain or through assist in
any other country i think our system's
still
still the best we certainly deliver just
just as we did with warp speed it didn't
surprise me that it was the united
states that drove
that outcome right we we got it we got a
cure
uh or at least a vaccine uh the chinese
brought us a virus
last thing is anything that you
centralize
and the way that we have centralized our
health care system we'll have enormous
bureaucratic mismanagement and a subject
politization
so if you said mike what's the one core
idea of how you you try and unpack this
entire labyrinth of our health care
system it would be to devolve as much
decision-making as you can to different
places starting frankly with our 50
little laboratories the states
you know president trump gave me a lot
of room to go work on religious liberty
we literally we prioritize this in a way
that no other administration has and it
didn't take 20 minutes for the byte
administration to knock the entire
edifice of religious liberty down not
one you've got some great leaders that
are serving in the united states senate
united states congress who care deeply
about religious liberty
you have big bureaucracies i spoke about
this at some length you have big
bureaucracies that want to do everything
they can to tear it down every place
they find it so i'll take a question
from over here now yes sir hi secretary
pompeo i just thank you for being here
i wanted to ask a little bit about our
um allies and the world and like the way
we've treated them in the past couple of
years with this new
administration
after we like left afghanistan china's
been pushing on those borders because
they want those rare earth minerals and
they've been really flexing because we
kind of lost our hold there
and russia is kind of seeing that as a
threat and so they're trying to move in
do you think that we still have like
enough standing there that if china or
russia makes a big push we can deter
them
oh the answer is yes the question is if
we have the capability the questions do
we have the will and the intent
to do so no there's there's no doubt
about the fact that we still have the
capability
i heard from leaders all across the
world after afghanistan and the question
was a little bit about afghanistan it
was a little bit about
uh the withdrawal but it was a lot about
america's credibility it was about the
commitments and promises that we had
made
uh look
i i i get it
i'll i will never forget the speech that
i gave in brussels i was there talking
about america first and i was demanding
that the european countries pick up more
of their fair share
i was in a room about this size with
about this many people these would have
been brussels bureaucrats from the eu
i walked out of that room in dead
silence
even my even my team that's around me
didn't even go hey that was that was
really good mr secretary
it was really good actually we were
right uh
we do have the moral standing in the
world to do this but we have to deliver
against that here at home and then we
have to demand it from our allies and
friends around the world and then we
have to make sure we don't make promises
we are not prepared to live up to we we
were very clear about this we i
everywhere i went we talked about
putting america at the top right my duty
i i raised my hand seven times to swear
allegiance to the constitution
seven times
every time it talked about the same
people
that i was tasked to work on behalf of
it was the american people we were clear
about that we were you know we were
pilloried in the left press in the
international press right for this idea
that america was special and exceptional
we wanted to defend it i knew if we did
that and did that well and did it right
every leader in the world would want to
see me because we'd make their country a
happier more prosperous successful place
too and so we worked on it by the way no
matter how bad a diplomat i was i never
had the french ambassador withdrawn on
my watch
just for the record
we have friends and allies because
america is a force for good in the world
we have to be sure that we we use that
skill set that talent set our
capabilities in a way that is
the founders talked about a restraint
right there was this tension about
international engagement
i think we struck the balance in a way
that made sure we preserve the things
that matter to america the interests
that we had that were important while
still reflecting
a force for good wherever we went in the
world anyway i hope that answers your
question at least in part we have time
for one more question very good
yes mr secretary yes sir thank you for
your uh dedication to duty both
militarily and
the highest levels of uh elsa lines in
this country and as the director of cia
and also secretary of state so
i personally appreciate it and i think
you're a great um
person in which our
upcoming kids can look up to thank you
that's very kind
i have two questions fairly simple but
maybe not depends how you want to
address them
one is in your
tenure as cia director and also your
tender as secretary of state
uh from your experience in those two
positions can you address briefly the
deep state that might exist
in our hierarchy within the government
our higher level bureaucracies today in
almost all of the secretary levels not
just the state and cia and also lastly
perhaps you can briefly address what you
perceive or what you might recommend
is where you see president trump might
play a role in this government's
uh presidency or
elected officials over the next
next year and also in 2024. sure no i'm
happy to take a swing at the first one
the second one's
trickier but but but you know
but but game on you know
uh
so
deep state from my perspective
doesn't capture the magnitude of the
problem
so yes it exists by the way different at
the two institutions i led very
different
institutions i saw different
institutions too the department of
education civil rights division civil
rights division the justice department
lost
lost what do i mean lost they are no
longer responsive to the political
leadership that exists in those places i
i certainly i i can't tell you how many
times i had to pass this the memo back
six times at the state department
to get them to acknowledge that like i
was in charge
right and it's not about ego it's i had
the duty the responsibility came with
the authority if it went badly it was
going to they weren't going to blend
them
it's a real challenge i have lots of
theories about how to
make it much better
because it's imperative
the administrative state has to respond
to what you all do we the first question
was about elections
right we're talking about making sure we
have a fair election the elections
mattered less if the administration just
goes on its way no matter who the
president is i wanted to make sure that
the state department was as responsive
to me as it was to hillary clinton
right no i mean i right
right i want i wanted to make sure right
if it's president obama the state
department should do the things that
president obama asked them to do this is
what our founders talked about there
weren't four branches six branches nine
branches state department thought it had
37.
um this is a serious matter that has to
be i'm taking there are three unions at
the state department
i mean the
the
we didn't get our political
people confirmed fast enough either it's
that political control that allows you
to drive effectively the operations that
president trump was asking me to go
deliver on right he set the policy he's
the one that sent me to pyongyang to
meet with chairman kim
and he's the one that sent me to know
how to meet with the taliban he's the
one who said i want you to go to sochi
and talk to vladimir putin if the entity
is not driving towards those very same
objectives you have a deeply
unconstitutional and frankly a very very
challenging situation
and we we probably suffered it as much
as any administration we're pretty
unique
in the way we approach the world and we
were different than previous republican
administrations as well
i i viewed that as a feature not a bug
but it made it made that task even more
difficult and the challenge of the
administrative state even more readily
apparent
second question
questions about 2022 and 2024 and
president trump's role in there
president trump was a leader who the
american people wanted
um
a significant number of the things that
i talked about there wouldn't have
happened with anyone else who was
running in that field at that time i'm
i'm convinced of it
he gave me a ton of space to go execute
on his vision as well
and now
conservatives i've been in i've been in
the movement for a long time lots of
different roles
from fifth grade sunday school teacher
to
you know
working on pro-life efforts and school
choice efforts back in kansas
those of us who believe in these things
all have to figure this out
people will start voting in the 2022
elections less than 12 months from now
it seems like a long ways off like we
just we just got through this last
election
it's upon us and president trump can be
an incredibly important part of doing
that i the first time i ran for office
was in 2010 came in with 70-something
republicans in the house of
representatives the big class the
so-called tea party class
it was the last time we threw nancy
pelosi out who would dream i'd be
campaigning trying to do it again
uh
i i pray that president trump will
continue to be a really important part
of that what what happens after that
president trump will have to make his
own set of decisions right he'll have to
figure out if this is the right place
and the right call for him
as will each
person who decides to put themselves
forward and offer their services to
america both the folks who are running
in 2022 and and those who choose to run
for president in 2024 as well anyway i
hope that answers your question at least
in part yeah
all right please join me got one more is
everybody else need to leave please join
me in thinking mr pompeo
thank you
thanks everybody thank you all
thank you
thank you
thank you bless you
thank you talk to my wife
we'll see y'all
[Applause]
okay thank you secretary pompeo and
thanks to all of you for joining us this
evening we're adjourned thank you very
much
you